[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in 2016 Marvel fans were over the moon
when the much-anticipated Black Panther
made his first iconic appearance in
Captain America Civil War officially
adding the superhero to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe fans wouldn't have to
wait long to see more of their favorite
crime fighting cat with the release of
the Black Panther movie two years later
now it's almost impossible to talk about
Black Panther without also recognizing
The Man Behind the Mask of course I'm
talking about the legendary Chadwick
Boseman who tragically passed in 2020
leaving behind his legacy to a franchise
it will forever deeply miss his presence
[Music]
laughs
my king stop it stop it
the MCU has been blessed with countless
Unforgettable moments of black panther
but we took it upon ourselves to put
together the greatest moments of them
all and just in case you haven't managed
to find wakanda yet this is your
official spoiler warning for all things
black panther including any appearances
in The Avengers franchise so suit up and
assemble as we count down our list of
the best black panther moments
[Applause]
[Music]
number 10 tachaka's final moment Captain
America Civil War arriving in Vienna to
a special un meeting of the sokovia
Accords Black Widow joins in attendance
with King t'chaka and Prince t'challa of
wakanda after showing his appreciation
for The Avengers support of the
initiative King tachaka shares a moment
with his son thanking him for standing
by his side little does to Chala know
that this will be the last few moments
he will share with his father t'chaka
delivers a moving speech of peace and
progress before he can finish however a
bomb is triggered outside t'challa
rushes to protect his father but isn't
able to reach him in time as the blasts
knocked them both back killing king
t'chaka
when stolen wakandan vibranium was used
to make a terrible weapon we in wakanda
were forced to question our Legacy
those men and women killed in Nigeria
were part of a good will Mission from a
country too long in the shadows
we will not however
let Misfortune drive us back we will
fight to improve the world we wish to
join
I am grateful to The Avengers for
supporting this initiative
wakanda is proud to extend his hand in
peace
number nine who are you black panther
in the closing moments of Black Panther
t'challa and shuri visit a neighborhood
in Oakland California the same
neighborhood that their father to Chaka
killed their uncle in jobu t'challa and
Sherry look upon the same rundown
apartment complex from the beginning of
the movie that killmonger was raised in
t'challa reveals that he has bought the
property and plans to open the first
wakandan International Outreach Center
in a hope to give back to the community
and is named shuri as the head of
Science and information much like the
opening of the movie they call in their
glider which attracts a group of the
neighborhood kids only this time one of
them notices t'challa and asks him who
he is
this would be the first walk on the
international Outreach Center
now Kia will oversee the social Outreach
you will spearhead the science and
information Exchange
you're kidding yeah
[Music]
oh my God
man what the hell is that that's like a
Bugatti space suit
wow what
you take this back to the house
hey look we can break it apart we can
sell it on eBay
hey yo
this yours
who
are you
oh
number eight t'challa returns Black
Panther
killmonger has taken full control of
wakanda and plans to use his power to
show the world their strength through
Force he prepares weapons and warriors
to send out to start his attack just at
that moment one of the gliders
unexpectedly explodes and crashes down
before them emerging From the Ashes is
t'challa whom they all thought to be
dead t'challa challenges killmonger for
his throne taking on a wave of Warriors
rhinos and eventually killmonger himself
the doctor
what's up
I never healed it
and as you can see
I am not dead
oh that challenge [ __ ] is over with I'm
the king now get those brains in the air
carry out the mission
[Music]
your heart is so full of hatred you are
not fits to be a king
ah
[Music]
a
[Music]
number seven Battle of wakanda Avengers
Infinity War
Thanos has begun his invasion of Earth
choosing wakanda as it's Ground Zero
standing in his way is a wakandan army a
group of angry Avengers and of course
black panther leading the charge with
Captain America they watch as a massive
Legion of thanos's army of monsters
descends to the ground led by one of his
adopted children Proxima midnight
wakanda is protected by an energy field
but as waves and waves of monsters Pile
in on top of each other they soon
overwhelm the defense and force The
Avengers to make the first move
following a signature wakanda forever
Black Panther and Captain America charge
thanos's monsters Avengers and wakandans
close behind
my signal
open Northwest section 17.
on my signal
[Music]
then it will be the noblest ending in
the history
[Music]
[Applause]
go
back
number six t'challa confronts Zemo
Captain America Civil War after learning
the man who's truly responsible for his
father's death t'challa confronts helmet
Zemo Zemo Reveals His plot to turn the
Avengers against each other to avenge
his wife and daughter that were killed
in sokovia although it driven to this
point of Vengeance and ready to end
zemo's life t'challa refuses to give in
to his loss for revenge and keeps Zemo
alive stopping his suicide attempt and
taking him prisoner instead
I knew I couldn't kill them
more powerful men than we have tried
but
if I could get them to kill each other
I'm sorry about your father
you seemed a good man
with a beautiful son
Vengeance has consumed you
he's consuming them
I'm done letting it consume me
[Music]
just as you will come soon enough
tell them to the Dead
living or not done with you yet
number five losing the throne Black
Panther
[Music]
and killing killmonger finally gets the
opportunity to challenge his cousin
t'challa the Black Panther for the
throne of wakanda as the two Warriors
prepare for their duel t'challa pleads
with killmonger to settle their
differences without violence but
killmonger intent on getting his revenge
refuses the two hash it out exchanging
brutal blows on one another and just as
it seems t'challa might come out on top
killmonger lands a fatal blow dropping
t'challa to the floor killmonger drags
t'challa to the edge of a waterfall and
throws him into the gorge below
seemingly killing him taking the crown
as the new king of wakanda
I live my entire life waiting for this
moment
I train I lie
killed
just to get here
killed in America
Afghanistan
Iraq
I took life from my own brothers and
sisters right here on this continent
and all this death
just so I could kill you
let the challenge
biggie
number four the snap Avengers Infinity
War
in the final moments of infinity War
Thanos has managed to acquire the sixth
and final infinity stone for his
Gauntlet in a last-ditch effort to stop
him Thor is able to strike his ax into
thanos's chest but it wasn't enough to
stop him as Thanos still manages to get
off his Unforgettable snap ending half
of life in the universe The Avengers are
left helpless as they watch their
friends disintegrate Into Thin Air in
his final moments t'challa finds Okoye
in the forest to try and help her
uttering his final words this is no
place to die before Vanishing himself
where'd he go
Steve
I'll turn around up
there's no place to die
[Music]
number three The ancestral plain black
panther
as t'challa prepares to take the Throne
of wakanda as black panther he undergoes
a ceremony in which he must first visit
the ancestral plain reliving his final
moments with his father before his death
t'challa is transported into the
ancestral plane where he's greeted by
his predecessors in the form of black
panthers one of the Panthers transforms
into his father to Chaka overcome with
emotion t'challa drops to his knees
before him before receiving some
fatherly and kingly wisdom t'chall
admits that although he may be ready to
be king he's not ready to be without his
father
foreign
[Music]
laughs
[Laughter]
only another one
[Music]
I'm sorry
stand up you are a king
number two imbambe Avengers end game
in the Epic finale to end games Thor
Iron Man and Captain America fight
Thanos but aren't able to defeat him his
army once again descends upon Earth
Captain America stands alone against
them until a mysterious portal opens
behind them the first to emerge is the
one and only black panther dozens of
portals open revealing all the Fallen
Avengers with the Black Panther leading
his army of wakandans chanting their
iconic war cry in Bombay as they all
assemble for this final and probably
most iconic battle against Thanos
Captain Sam can you hear me
on your left
[Music]
[Music]
he broke back
okay
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Star-Lord t'challa what if
Marvel's what if turns the Marvel
Cinematic Multiverse on its head and
asks what if t'challa king of wakanda
was instead t'challa Guardian of the
Galaxy t'challa as Star-Lord goes head
to head with the collector as him in the
ravagers which also includes the
reformed Thanos create an elaborate
Heist to steal seeds that could end
Hunger across the Galaxy although
posthumously awarded Chadwick Boseman
would win an Emmy for his role astachala
for outstanding character voice over
performance
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what kind of being leaves a party
without saying goodbye something tells
me this happens to you a lot
[Music]
packs quite a while up does it not I
hacked it off the carcass of a terribly
chatting quote
of course if that's not your style
there's plenty more we can play with
observe
a dagger forced in Dark Matter taken
from the ruler of the Dark Elves but
perhaps you prefer something a touch
more elegant
[Music]
oh that woman had tastes a natural sword
courtesy of the Asgardian goddess of
death
black panther versus the Winter Soldier
Captain America Civil War
on the hunt for Bucky the Winter Soldier
for a terrorist attack in Vienna Captain
America and Falcon track him down to his
hideout in Romania now they intend to
capture him alive as they believe he was
really brainwashed by Hydra little do
they know that the Black Panther is also
on the scene out to avenge the death of
his father as Bucky and Captain America
fight their way through German Special
Forces bucking nearly escapes but is
stopped by the Black Panther after a
dramatic Chase through the tunnels of
Bucharest the Black Panther manages to
stop the Winter Soldier but is arrested
before he can get his revenge this
moment is the first introduction of
t'challa as the Black Panther to the
entire MCU
dude
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
congratulations cap
Criminal
[Music]
[Music]
and finally number one death is better
than bondage black panther after a
thrilling fight between Black Panther
and killmonger in the caverns of wakanda
t'challa is able to land the final
killing blow on killmonger but instead
of finishing him off or leaving him for
dead t'challa pity's killmonger and
takes him to an Overlook to see wakanda
a final time and although t'challa
believes that they might still be able
to save killmonger's life killmonger
refuses he only asks that they throw his
remains in the ocean to be with his
ancestors who believed that death was
better than bondage
foreign
maybe we can still heal you
so you can just lock me up
no
just bury me in the ocean
but my ancestors that jumped from the
ships
because they knew death was better than
bondage
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love of course
until next time I am your host Naz Perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]